what's your favorite memory of being on
star trek you you mentioned it earlier
walking in that little place where you
could see the the whole ship right yeah
um
i uh
god you know the thing is like there's
so many there are so many incredible
memories i'm trying to pick one that's
really cool that that will that will
that your pa that your patreon will be
like yay i'm glad that they chose that
one on stage
nine the stage where the where the
corridor is right it's where the
transporter room is and it's where the
engine room is right
more than once
teenage me walked in there walked into
the transporter room
pretended to be
beamed into the enterprise
walked down the corridor to engineering
and turned on the engine
it's just neon lights
right on a timer so like they they
strobe you know but i knew where the
switch was
and i was like yes i will activate the
engines for the enterprise and i did
that
so
so from from one point of view teenager
walks down the wall walks through the
set and turns on the lights okay that's
great
that's not what that was for me
that was for the little boy who
at
five years old
listened to
star trek records
in the on the little fisher price record
player because i wanted star trek all
the time
i wanted i just i wanted nothing but
science fiction when i was a little boy
that's all i wanted
um
uh yeah like i was super primed for star
wars when star wars happened because i
was already in the like i was already
way into science fiction but like
when i did that and i turned that on
i was a person making the engine of the
enterprise start
i love that and that was pretty that and
that was pretty great i love that